ce que nous visons c'est à équiper les
plus précaires nous et qui pour les plus
précaires parts des distributions en
travers des mairies et des préfets et
nous appuyant sur les collectivités
locales et les salariés qui ne peuvent
pas respecter la distanciation physiques
sont également équipés mais est ce que
l'on trouverait normal et j'aurais voulu
interpeller madame la sénatrice cohen
distribué des masques gratuits à ceux
dont elle voudrait qu'ils recommencent à
payer l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune
cela me paraît très très incohérent vous
abordez justement ce sujet votre point
de vue sur et bien toute cette partie de
la gauche qui réclame et bien le retour
de l' isf mais ils sont pas les seuls
par exemple un conseiller comme raymond
soubie
raymond soubie dit lui est bien le
gouvernement va difficilement pouvoir
faire l'économie de revenir sur cette
réforme du début du quinquennat
moi je crois que l'on se trompe de
combat aujourd'hui l'impôt le fait de
remettre l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune ça représenterait une recette de
l'ordre de 2 milliards d'euros par an
mais un symbole important comme 1,2
milliard d'euros par an face à 110
milliards en 2 mois de dépenses faites
par l'état ce n'est pas du tout au
niveau des enjeux que nous devons
affronter
par ailleurs est ce que vraiment on
croit que c'est le moment de matraquer
les français avec de l'impôt alors que
nous sommes tous en train d'affronter
une crise enfin est-ce qu'après 30 ans
d'impôt sur la fortune
est-ce qu'on va vraiment régler le
problème de l'hôpital public je ne crois
pas en revanche on a pu voir que depuis
trois ans notre politique économique a
permis de recréer de l'emploi de baisser
le chômage et donc je crois aussi qu'il
faut savoir reconnaître quand des
décisions sont bonnes et quand elles
sont efficaces pour l'économie